hold up one last question so when you're
out there do you just black out no
or
or do you
or do you do she just wakes up
after usc just wakes up
i'm not touching you dude
[Music]
you don't do anything but drink water
higher no he doesn't drop out he doesn't
steal's not in here so i got a little
whiskey in my cup okay yeah where's theo
he's in nashville man and yeah he
couldn't [ __ ] he's gonna find a producer
to help him zoom it in huh nick you know
what he was at the fights man he was
there like he was like backstage and
yeah he went with spade and then
obviously he's boys pictures with gaichi
and he's boys with poirier they put him
on the ufc uh
on the ufc instagram yeah oh wow yeah
so he's big time now huh private jets i
i don't think he's flying private
obviously you know theo he's a penny
pinterest
flying spirit yeah and if david if uh
spade hits him up for private i think
what are your thoughts on the the the
juliana pena upsetting uh a man like
everyone watching you probably didn't
watch
you don't you dude that was a stunning
one i'm not into fighting because i
don't like it's too violent and i'm
really not into women fighting that's
fair i don't like looking at that yeah
you know don't worry
that's or you're you're a feminist you
know you're not you're an anti no no i
just no i don't the way i was raised man
yeah i don't like seeing women get in
the face now
i'm different i get that
it's different i think like
if you look at like a paige van zandt
who or you know uh rachel ostovich who
are just dime pieces and when they in
the face i'm like oh goddamn rose is
pretty too she is pretty she's really
pretty yeah different like you look at
paige it's like super model yeah joseph
supermodels yeah some of these girls but
then if they're like warlocks like hell
yeah let's do this i just i don't like
it man i don't like by the way i don't
like my my buddy i have a buddy of mine
eric you know eric coke you know what i
mean what you said you know
eric you know
i kind of like watching you fight
because he's my friend yeah we play
video games with him we met him playing
destiny yeah we got to know this guy he
became our friend yeah and then it's
hard watching him oh rogan used to cry
oh yeah i'm sure he's doing the same
thing with you
i can't hate it that's why i can't do it
so i don't like what and that's that's
what i'm saying i don't like watching
women fight like ours we we're brought
up we're brought up to to like you know
you don't hit women so apparently it's
okay for women to get hit at this
pay-per-view well it gets another woman
though yeah steven still wait wait let
me ask you something let me ask you
something old school he's like
here's the thing let me ask you this
okay so
who's who's this chick that just fought
the female champ pena okay juliana pena
julian
amanda nunez okay so both mom so let me
ask you this both moms
who's doing more damage
if i hit
one of these chicks in the face yeah or
one of them hit each other in the face
if a man of nuna has hit you yeah
let's take steve knock you out man if
you
you know what i'm talking about amanda
and nunes would probably do more damage
okay okay a man who wouldn't know what
we wanted no no no no excuse me you're
not you're missing the whole point what
are you saying you're missing you're
missing a point because you're not
listening
for a second
[Applause]
[Applause]
so what i'm saying is my point is if if
there therefore like if i hit
this chick in the face everybody would
flip out and be like a man just kidding
but this chick who's trained a trained
killer hits her in the face and we're
like this is cool but she's another
female as long as we were but they're
another female
and she didn't like if you think that
matters that's the hypocrisy of the
whole thing i just don't like it i don't
like none of that i don't want to see
you to get hit in the face you're a big
[ __ ] monster that's fair and i don't
want to see a hundred pounds no i get it
you know whatever 120 pound chick get
hit in the face
you never was a fan of ufc or any of
them no no no no no i don't even like
boxing you never liked it no because i
could never you don't like people
getting hurt yeah especially when boxing
even worse because look all these boxy
people they can't talk yeah they're
getting ms they get like and i'm just
like oh man those violent sports i'm out
were reinstated i just i get not like
enjoying watching it but but your
reasoning like if if she gets hit by
amanda it's not like amanda was popping
up at dinner so she got popped it was
she's like i want to go to war i signed
up for this competition yeah do you want
do you want to say all i'm saying is
like just any kind of like that kind of
violence violence you don't like it i
just don't like it what's up kids hey
listen two out of three bros will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35. more than 50 million
dudes in the u.s of a suffer from male
pattern baldness i see it man i'm on the
road all the time a lot of y'all using
your hair
you're looking like george costanza it's
not good man my friends at keeps offers
a simple stress-free way to keep your
hair slow-cost treatments start just ten
dollars per month is your long locks
were ten dollars i think so
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors prevention is key
treatment start uh
listen it takes four to six months see
results so act right now if you're ready
to take action prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com k-a-t-s that's k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash cats to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash cats get your
first month free keeps dot com slash
cats he likes basketball yeah just but
that's violent
not these days and football i mean even
though you don't look up you don't so
the only sport professional sport you
watch is nba no no i watch i like the
nfl i like the basketball nfl's not too
violent for you no because they at least
have equipment
no no by the way
it's hypocrisy i know the hypocrisy i
get it because you guys are [ __ ] like
yeah they really get messed up
especially with the cte and all the
stuff they're talking about but
there's just something about
a mono imano violence on each other i
just but football's mono a model but
you're just looking at the grand yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
the offensive
break linebacker but then they just keep
going it's three hours you know what i
know i have to rethink it but
i just can't
i just when especially ufc especially
when it looks like they're like barely
covering their knuckles it feels like
you know at least gloves it's crazy
because when you watch boxing it feels
like they're safer because they got that
big ass which is insane because they're
they're clubs right and they're 10 ounce
gloves and if you've ever seen like
deonte waller's hand or like mike
tyson's
that 10-ounce glove is spread over their
entire it's nothing bro it's enough it
looks like it's more it's all awesome
but then when you look at a ufc it just
feels like
how's that it's it feels like because
you could see their hands yeah so you
don't think it's much but it's no no i
think it's worse
it looks worse to me but according to
like all you you see the fight
ufc is safer than boxing way safer yeah
and it's just like that's the thing that
blows my mind so like if you had to look
at like the violence level if you look
at the violence level is it football
boxing ufc which one of these three is
more violent to the more dangerous to
the humans to the common fan yeah to the
people or just in real life what's the
actual oh football football football
concussions man crazy yeah crazy
football guys 270 pounds running four
340s running straight and face first
into each other
yeah
i know ladies and gentlemen but then but
then you have these you know two people
in a ring that are like just looking to
just beat each other
i saw the clip of that fight those two
chicks fighting yeah and like she was oh
my god and then after it was done
the other one hugged the other one like
i was like two moms bro i was like what
are you guys doing
nick you bet on the fights oh yes
[Music]
well i sent you this screenshot which
was like me chasing smart juliana pena
trying if she won in third fourth or
fifth i was going to sizzler it would
have been a great day but she won in the
second sizzler
but uh
my actual picks that i put out and like
i let people see publicly i went an
unbelievable 0 for 8. if you would have
parked that's hard to do if you would
have parlayed the opposite of my pitch
you've been balling oh for eight oh
that's great tie to ivasa dustin poirier
miranda maverick well tied to avasta one
uh uh oh i'm sorry i had a guess this
guy yeah uh yeah it was bad it was it
was
this guy's got a related debate club i
think we know everybody's answers but uh
we'll it'll bring up something else hey
guys what's up this is asher calling out
of virginia
i was just driving down the road
thinking a little bit today
and uh
have a debate club for you guys
i saw the rat king sitting beside that
beautiful man david spade
at the poirier fight
and just got to thinking
you got your [ __ ] pick
would you rather be sitting ringside
with the rat king and spade
or
front row
at that yeezy jesus
drake concert
that's a tough one
let me know what you guys do no that's
not tough at all ufc all the way oh
really i'd go kanye yeah me too i don't
want to say that
kanye hasn't performed in five
years about i didn't go to ufc
the question was i want to sit with theo
and david spade
like take them out of it just talk about
it
just like ufc i want to go to ufc i've
never been i've never been to ufc who
wants to hang out with those two but
let's just so let's take let's say dave
and theo yeah we got to take them from
cage side ufc mike tyson or
if i was sitting next to mike tyson that
would be something special well whoever
let's just say inside you can pick
whatever celebrity wants stevie for
god's sakes so let's say cage side ufc
state's like i want to sit next to e
honda yeah
from street fighter
caitlyn jenner hello
yeah whoever he wants steven don't you
start with me this earlier i used to
love it
and do this yeah like you're cheating
um
i i would pick kanye drake from bro all
day yeah
i don't know dude have you been to a
concert lately it's not what it used to
be what's the last concert you went to
uh that's a good question
the best concert i've ever seen is drake
in person and then drake and kanye two
monsters
you have the best seats in the house
steve steve can you see steven at k-pop
concert
well i got him wait hold up i didn't
mean to interrupt but i made something
specifically for him uh oh here we go
let's take a little break from chatting
with the boys man cause listen is there
something interfering with your
happiness and preventing you from
achieving your goals
whatever it is man get out of your way
man and my friends that better help will
help you out all right they're going to
match you with your own license
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
christ science not self-help it's
profession now professionals counseling
done securely online all right um the
service is available worldwide
world freaking wide it's more affordable
than traditional offline counseling
financial aid is also available better
help once you start living a happier
life today all right visit their website
read their testimonials listen they're
the best there is in this space man
visit
betterhelp.comcats that's
betterhelp.comcats
join over 1 million people have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of the experienced professional in
fact so many people have been using
better help they're recruiting
additional
counselors in all 50 states that's crazy
this episode of king of the sting is
brought to you by betterhelp all right
and kingston listeners and viewers get
tempted off their first month
at betterhelp.com k-a-t-s listen man
when it comes to health care it's
important to make sure you're getting
your money's worth all right and that's
where crowd health comes in crowd health
offers a more flexible affordable health
care option without the hassle of
insurance so while you're shopping
around don't forget to head to join
crowdhealth.com fit to find out how
crowd health can save you up to 40 50 60
off health care costs each year it isn't
health insurance all right it's a modern
way to pay medical expenses crowd health
is community of people who are tired of
paying into a broken system all right
being in the crowd health community can
save hundreds of dollars monthly and put
thousands of dollars back in your pocket
it's flexible it's simple it's an app
man you can scan your bit scan your
bills throw them away crowd health takes
it all from there all right it's a
membership crowd health gets rid of
insurance middleman and passes the
savings to its members 100 of your
monthly membership pays for actual
healthcare cost all right crowdhealth is
a able to offer amazing prices because
of a community of health conscious
members but for limited time kingston
listeners and viewers get their first
month free all right after you've been a
member crowd health will include a
fitness wearable that's fun that's 30
days try risk free plus the fitness
wearable just go to joincrowdhealth.com
fit enter the code kats at sign up
that's join
fit promo crowdhealth.com kats all right
uh crowd health is not health insurance
it's a community powered alternative
terms conditions apply what is i'm going
to ask you something what is the thing
he tells me the most steve
blank
listen
what do you got
is that steve listen merch
steve you're not listening that's
hilarious
that's hilarious
so i could just stare at you and know
that i'm not listening
yeah yeah just do that every time
you should wear it hopefully you guys
know i smell it that's that's his size
okay no i get it but i would love to go
so angry yeah you look good because
you're watching women fight it used to
be like like let's say back in the day
going going to see led zeppelin dude not
something special oh yeah you ever been
to travis scott concert
i don't want to do that
dude i don't want a double nike's lace
to that doesn't look fun
gasping for air legally well i heard
that the kanye drake concert it was more
a kanye concert than a drake you know
you that's what everybody's talking
about so i'm i love drake i love both of
them but
in my household my brother's super pro
kanye i'm super drake i like both of
them right right so for this it was like
let's say it was a virtuous battle and i
actually have some background on this so
kanye did you you forget his catalog
it's stupid yeah yeah so how many albums
you don't know you could say how
a million so he so he did like his hits
and then drake came out and just did his
new stuff and i was like well one's
playing hall of fame hits the others
playing his new stuff and i figured it
out obviously the people on reddit
figured it out so drake doesn't own his
masters and since that was on amazon he
can't do his hits he only owns his new
stuff so since amazon that's why he did
only his [ __ ]
i don't know
that's crazy terrible
oh because the concert was
recorded and it streamed like i watched
it i had fomo for the first time a long
time uh streamed live on amazon oh oh
but they're both like in person so he
got taylor swifted yeah
so are we talking front row seats like
where are the best seats in the house
best ufc see that changes it then best
ufc seats in the house
okay let's talk about what's the last
concert that you actually have gone to
you didn't say cause i know the last
concert i went to well you weren't you
uh i'll think about it you you did you
the last concert i went to was a justin
bieber concert nice and i was sitting
there and girl fortune you know that no
no i went because i know you know you
don't know john the nelco boys i don't
know boys but but you know john
yeah john
yes he used to be like he used to work
with bieber you know what i mean like he
used to be like his handler type of
thing like his go-to guy for stuff so i
went to the concert because of him you
know what i mean and i've met bieber
many times but i was sitting like i take
it easy i was no no i was sitting like
bieber's like right here yeah you know
get called up in your face yeah yeah
this is like you're just looking at
everybody just going we're in this like
vip sort of thing take tacos or viewing
it from there yeah like idiot but you
know what was crazy this is at a time
that he was going through some stuff
because like i'm looking at him you're
sad panda dude
like not even singing a song is he like
this
what do you mean not singing this song
i'm telling you man he was just like
that's not a concert they they're
lip-syncing then it was crazy
is the thing is i got love for that kid
because think he's been famous for so
long and everything's under a microscope
how did he make it again youtube i
forgot i was like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i sure found him on
youtube on youtube
because he's super talented yeah he's
been tempted since he was nine years old
stupid town no but here's what happens
here's what happens to someone like that
he's nine years old and everybody tells
him you're great he's like oh man no i'm
not great i'm only nine then 10 years
old you're great then 11. you're great
about 14 he was like well maybe you know
the 15 was like am i great and then when
he turned 18 he was like i think i'm
pretty great and then everybody went
hold on kid yeah slow it down and feel
bad to hate him you feel bad for him
yeah and then he was like lashing out
into the public guy and then yeah he's
like trying to figure himself out i
think he's figured it out he figured out
now he's getting like tattoos and [ __ ]
is he on drugs is he doing drugs he used
to i think you think he was yeah i think
he saw him right right oh the pixies
that was the last concert hanging out
with carl
bieber got sober uh he's good he's good
now we're a little bit he got married
he's good you know what i mean they seem
to be happy so i'm a fan yeah me too man
i love bieber but yeah
and also i'm what's the last count you
probably went to some like
god
everybody's trying to slam with you
yeah and they don't know what a teddy
bear you are you're like hey guys
not my big boy merch i hate i hate
crowded areas so i don't get a lot of
concerts i think glass concert
i mean probably drake in uh fiddler's
green in denver is probably the last one
man really yeah i don't i i see i'm not
you know i'm not then also ufc obviously
i'm biased i think people thought i
would say ufc the ufc because i fought
it and it was like
i have great memories in the ufc but
when i entered that like arena and i see
hear the crowd and i see the cage i
those smells it triggers me to horrible
anxiety what do you mean like i can't
even touch down in vegas without being
triggered what does it smell like can
you describe the smell it's it smells
like uh fear it smells like fear is it
like just you know a gladiator when that
guy's uh changed i just watched that
movie i just watched gladiators that's
what it feels like oof like russell yeah
yeah it's it's really really intense so
for me it's really really intense is it
the same way you get before stand up how
you get adrenaline rush no if for stand
up i'm super excited i can't wait to go
you're not nervous at all i'm nervous
but i'm more excited because i can
control the narrative so fighting i
can't control
so fighting is a lot more scary or like
you're like oh i might die
yeah i'm close
no my question is how do you deal with
that how do you calm yourself down to
get focused like you just trust in the
process like all the training camp
you've been in you know that's what's
about to say
now this is where it is similar because
what he's saying is like you can't
control it but you you get confident in
your skills because you've practiced so
hard i know it's the best version of
myself that enters that outcome and i
put that trust in it stand up stand up
you have to practice practice practice
do it do it so you're confident when you
get into the situation so like like when
i shot my 30-minute special in dallas
right
i wasn't like i think my team cause my
team shot it right we sold it my team
was like man i thought you'd be more
nervous like why like i've been it's
been three years in the making man i
know exactly what to hit i know exactly
what to do i can control the narrative
when i shot my showtime special it's not
like i knew i wasn't ready so i was so
nervous because you know like you know
when you shoot specials or if you're
doing a tv or something you know if
you're ready for it or not so you knew
backstage you're like oh no
for showtime yeah yes you felt these
feelings yeah
brian had to give me like this long talk
which is rare for me yeah
were you shaking back like were you no
i'm not shaking jesus christ dude it's
just a calmness
shaking i was shaking before this guy
never gets tired i'm shaking before i
fight travis brown i know steve acts
like it was like you know in uh saving
private ryan like right before those
things went down
yeah like we're storming normandy
yeah it's the same thing here we go
i don't know though man i mean that's
must be nerve-wracking man to especially
like to walk to the octagon i always
like try to put myself in their shoes no
no that must be scary no the walks yeah
once you hit the music and once you hit
the crowd the music plays there's no
turning back and it's just like here we
go oh my god the worst is waiting in the
ho in the behind the [ __ ]
drapes and you and you're just sitting
there you hear the crowd you're like
what the [ __ ] am i doing and then his
team's behind oh no see him like
god yeah all right here we go you know
it's so intense dude what about the ride
when they announce your name and
introducing in this corner you know like
do you get excited when you do the face
off and all that
no it's very rare i get excited it was
your walk out song yeah yeah uh eminem
square dance oh
people
so do when you hold up one last question
so when you're out there do you just
black out no
or
or do you
or do you just wakes up
like have you been in a fight where you
were like oh this game plan ain't going
to work yeah
like the one after every time i was like
oh he's too big for this [ __ ] man no one
thought this through yeah you're like if
you get hit with the big shot does it
like rattle you and you see stars and
you're like oh no it doesn't hurt it's
just like it's like
it's like a ringing no there's a real
ringing yeah and then a sense of like oh
[ __ ] so it's like yeah
never hurts inside there it's when you
walk out it [ __ ] hurts oh my god
because your adrenaline is so high like
you'll just hear a ring you're like i
got clip
god dude
it's weird it props to you man you did
it when you look back in fights yeah you
ever look back at your fights and then
look at it and be like what was i doing
oh dude
well i got my son one to see him so i
was showing him uh fights i went on
fight pass and looked at all my fights
and i was like how do we know that dude
what the [ __ ] is he doing
what are you doing but then it triggers
like my old sets like that yeah
then it triggers memories of like that
week and what happened and like that
training camp and it's crazy man that's
insane yeah it's so strange what a ride
i blame uh brian cowan for losing a ton
of money on uh you during the andre
arlovsky fight he wouldn't engage but he
just had you so hyped up that that that
camp
i believe bryant but now now i know
brian hypes everything yeah yeah
yeah uh but
yeah our last game was tough man it was
a bummer well because we were training
partners so when you know each other
there's like this weird
it's terrible when training partners
fight because i knew what he was good at
he knew what i was good at so we really
didn't do that so then you get this
weird awkward dance and then we're we're
friends
so then like i could tell like when i
was against holding him against cage i
like he was like yeah let's rest here
and then when he held me i was like yeah
let's chill here you guys i was just
about to say hey you guys talk no we
don't talk oh
yeah you ain't [ __ ] no you don't talk
no you don't talk but you know like if a
guy didn't want to be yeah
in the locker room came to me was like
i'll give you my half my payment you
know what i didn't what he said
you know what we need to do is what we
need to do is we need to do a fight
companion but watching his fights that'd
be cool and then just talk about your
fights what was happening that'd be fun
that'd be fun
would it really be fun for you yeah yeah
it'd be fun it was i got some store
right that'd be great like the
brazilians big knives that's how we
should do that we set that up
we'll do that for sure
i want to do that like when i was
getting ready to fight big nog and i was
like i was like sleeping
in brazil and i'm like man it smells
like like toxins in there well like it
smells like like there's fumes in here
so what they you know brazil it's like
fighting michael jordan chicago so what
brazil did is they backed up the trucks
into my green room what so all the fumes
went into my green room what so i was
like disqualification she's so sick
dude you're hearing this nick
chin yeah qualification i'll write a
letter yeah that's cheating
that's [ __ ] up man and then at that
two uh
i'll finish on this then we'll wrap up
my [ __ ] ufc story we love it though
so then before the fight you fight no
gear right and i was the favorite i
supposed to knock his old ass out so
he's
anonymous like really known for this uh
soccer league and soccer's huge in
brazil yeah the these two russian i'm
sorry these two brazilian gangsters set
when i was at dinner just sat down full
suit sat down don't speak any english
but my jutsu coach is fluent in
portuguese so he's talking and he's like
hey man just so you know these guys are
like
brazilian mafia and they want you they
have a jersey for you and when you knock
out noguera you put this jersey on
they're gonna give you 80 000 cash i'm
like yeah say less dude [ __ ] you i'll do
that he's like so they're going to come
tonight before the fight then put the 80
grand of cash in the
in the little locker that's in your
hotel room but only they know the code
so after you knock them out they're
going to call your room and give you the
code i'm like [ __ ] yeah this is dope i
lose the fight i'm back in my room my
[ __ ] eyes out to here my whole
family's around me knock on the door
it's time to come get that money who the
[ __ ] is that yeah i was like i don't
know answer the door dad answer it's
those two [ __ ] just muscle mafia
mafiosos and they go we're so sorry and
take the cash oh my god and they go but
you can't keep the jersey oh yeah yeah
damn that's like a movie man
holy smokes i'll probably frame that
jersey yeah you gotta wear that to an
episode yeah i will to the fight company
my dad has it
uh speaking of upcoming episodes send in
christmas related submissions and like
end of year new year's related
submissions for the next two weeks yeah
send in the worst gift you ever got for
christmas oh i like that yeah
the worst gift you've ever given for
christmas yeah
yes that's good should we do secret
santa yeah
we we've done it every year we do a
little white house oh so next week we do
uh christmas
secret santa next uh we'll do white
elephant we'll talk about it after uh
it's usually a little like jokey cheap
gift and then i already got mine
yeah no that's not your gift dude
that would have been money actually you
just ruined it
that would be great but now it's ruined
this guy's looking for some relationship
advice though
what's up boys sammy j back again i need
some relationship advice a bar stool hat
girl of two months
very cool get along
i respect her
big problem though drinking i'm talking
like we pick up a bottle of tiger thick
whiskey crush it having a good time
then it's kind of like a different
person at the end oh my goodness like it
just doesn't make sense
it's only two months in
what do i do run brother
well i'd say right away follow your gut
like if you feel like something's up and
you don't feel like this is right two
months feel like it's out of no no i'm
thinking i'm feeling like it's already
he already feels uncomfortable no i'm
with you but too much like two months in
this time to [ __ ] ejac bubba no yeah
a year well that's what i'm saying like
you already know you're you're not
comfortable yeah this ain't right you
know
my first suggestion is to say something
about it like do we have to drink all
the time because she might be like this
is what i do i this is how i need to get
turned up she might have a drinking
problem right so i'm saying so you need
to find out by just being up front and
just being like i have a problem with us
drinking so much like this yeah i don't
like who you become yeah
can we limit to like one or two drinks
yeah and if she's like i don't want to
do that then you know you got to get out
because it's only going to get worse
wait he's already uncomfortable he
already don't like it
dude
yeah
yo holidays are here and the holidays
can be hectic but thank god for
hellofresh they keep things simple with
recipes that cut back on meal prep and
clean up so you can spend less time in
the kitchen and more quality time with
your friends and family
hellofresh offers 50 menu and market
items choose from every single week
whatever diet you're on vegetarian we
got you covered man calorie smart
gourmet options providing plenty of
variety so you never get sick of it all
right listen the holidays are nuts man
so you gotta act right now and uh
freaking hellofresh is here to help you
out man and what are they going to do
for you i'm glad you act asked go to
hellofresh.com 14 king use the code 14
king for up to 14 free meals and three
free gifts that is
hellofresh.com14 king use the code 14
king for up to 14 free meals and three
free gifts all right
uh hello fresh is america's number one
meal kit
listen the winner's here and the flu is
popping up and sickness is popping up
and you're working out and you're
dehydrated and you're you're like well
it's cold out so listen i don't need to
hydrate you're wrong man you're wrong
listen the flu season is in full swing
and hydration is a priority it is key
and that's where liquid iv comes in to
help you out man liquid iv and 16 ounces
of water hydrates faster more
efficiently than water alone all right
all you do i put in a little eight
ounces of water before i work out it's
delicious and i feel fantastic again
liquid iv hydrates faster than water
alone
contains essential vitamins all right
more vitamin c than an orange we got
potassium more potassium than the banana
it's healthier than those sugary drinks
you can buy at the gym all right and
liquid iv they also they're here to
change the world the company is donating
four million servings of response to
kobe 19. products are being donated to
hospitals first responders food banks
veterans active military liquid iv has
donated over 11 million servings
worldwide all right so it's a good cause
and you stay hydrated grab your favorite
liquid iv flavors mine's watermelon
nationwide at walmart or you can get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
the code kats at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you get better
hydration today all right get better
hydration right now use problem code
kats at
liquidive.com so we're we a couple weeks
ago it's been a while now we had alabama
submit she wanted to play the dating
game ooh she was bad find a look yeah
let's see what's up with it yeah so uh
yeah
i forgot which one this one is let's see
you'll remember
i can't wait she was uh the pretty
blonde we're gonna bring her out let's
get it done baby we're gonna bring up
around soon
and then uh look at some of her
submissions she's gonna pick three of
them yeah i love this you'll remember
her she had them houses oh okay
yeah yeah oh there oh you don't remember
you don't remember
like super cute ronda rousey
yes this is lost i can hear you yeah
stevie yeah okay
good how are you guys we're chilling
we're good we're good
a lot better now it's real [ __ ] festival
let's get you locked in
what was that we're gonna get you locked
up with somebody let's figure it out all
right fingers crossed let's see how is
the uh d
your hometown's where
uh salem oregon oh okay so a lot of soy
boys up there so for you it's yeah yeah
very low energy
yeah hunting
yep democratic uh so for you
how's the dating scene been lately
before we get into this
um not that great but i also haven't
really been trying because like you said
they're all soy boys out here yeah um
but
your guys's fans blew me up you guys
have some wild fans
seven were my troll accounts yeah yeah
like how or how do you how do you
normally date though what's your normal
are you are you are you a dating app
person or what do you normally do
um i've tried dating apps before and
it's not bad it's just not great um
so i guess that's the route that i take
people in my hometown i'm kind of like
over that they're everyone's like grew
up here and it's still here so it's just
not great um so i guess dating apps is
basically what i do um because i'm not
going to run into someone at the grocery
store you know no you never know if
you're open to i don't know have you
been on a date from like someone dming
you or anything like that like don't a
lot of people meet on social media these
days or
no
no um some people will like slide in
your dms and stuff but not worth it
creeps no yeah they're creeps would you
be at that some of them are nice but
steve's gonna go ahead would you be open
to dating um
christian or kyle
because i mean i'm open to dating
anybody i guess do you have a height
requirement like what's your style like
these are studs who's your celebrity
crush just so we can kind of get a
visual of what we're looking for here
um well my celebrity crush is probably
ryan reynolds because
obviously he's hot and his personality i
love
and humor yeah funny guys yeah yeah but
it's funny that you mentioned how he
looks first
well i got one more question are you
open to dating ethnic guys
yes yeah latinos
yeah i don't discriminate
okay
black guys are wearing the black guys
indian guys
sure yeah
are you gonna go through the whole year
i know she's gonna be steve's
okay so is this guy live or he's just
submitting uh these are just some of her
submissions uh alabama hasn't seen these
and she she can't see him right now
she's only picking three guys based off
what they said just their voice yeah
alabama is there
are you a tall girl
i'm five five oh okay perfect a little
shorty all right all right little short
short queen what these guys are five
four five five two nine hey stevie hey
we gotta get it yeah we get it all right
let's get to trying to find some real
love let's get to the profile sorry
sorry
all right hit it what's up guys this is
my submission video for bama gillette's
fine ass yep what a [ __ ] name by the
way okay
eric man 63 200
perfect amount of man for her
all right i'm a funny outgoing type of
guy low energy i like all that outdoor
stuff all that kind of stuff
you know i like that she included about
being able to give each other [ __ ]
because
it's a relationship without a little
roasting going on i am from the east
coast i'm from new york pennsylvania ooh
too far
absolutely come across the states for
that west coast hitter baby
so
i like your boy i think you might gossip
he's a little too cool for school for me
yeah what do you mean by that and then
and like his eyebrow is like four inches
away from his eye it's a little weird
for me and they're separated very far
like his eyebrows like
things like this though
like a hairline yeah
is not right i don't like how cool he
was for school you know what i'm saying
like he's like this the whole time you
know like what's up
so you're fine
he's confident
he's confident all right let's see the
next guy let's see the other guy looks
friendly as she already kind of like him
how you doing alabama my name is peter
i'm 31 years old from albany oregon 20
minutes away from where you are
a little bit about me i'm a youngster
six of my family
so i know what it's like to be [ __ ] on
but until i was adopted my whole life
you know mom tells me i'm adopted
there'll me some issues inside the road
they picked me up
said fortune cookie at an asian
restaurant they gave me away
you know all the [ __ ] you know so i know
how to give [ __ ] back
uh a little spend time my family my
friends you know no girls never really
give me the the opportunity
to take them out you know been rejected
my whole life what's the diamond in the
rough
all right
alabama's diamond in the rough that
diamond is rough but i think there's
some potential
this is you if you let yourself go yeah
like if you want a desert deserted
island for like yeah for like two years
yeah desert yeah
[Applause]
wait wait wait wait hold on didn't he
just say he knows how to roast yeah yes
i know yeah yeah oh okay
he looks korean
i like him
he looks like he's half he's happy he's
alabama i like him better than the first
guy he seems he seems nice give him a
shot but this guy is nice that's what
we're going to give him a shot
here's my problem nick with all this
like what what
like alabama was a straight smoke show
bro you guys
steve what he just said is worse than
anything i said no okay your whole tone
was just like i said man i'm trying to
help okay here we go here we go here we
go this guy looks all right right
nothing let's hear it let's see what he
says
let's hear him out
you guys are scaring me i'm sorry you're
good you're good i'm trying to look out
for you though yeah
i appreciate it his eyebrows are at
least a normal length he reaches normal
distance he talks down quiet so okay
what's up bro it's getting out like that
so my name's nicholas i'm 25 years old i
also live in salem oregon and what made
me interested was a lot of things that
you said i can relate to as well i like
to travel my sense of humor is really
sarcastic and there's no bounds we both
seem to have a good sense of humor since
we both listen and watch the same
podcast i like to play and watch sports
not trying to brag but my fancy football
team multiples orgasms is number one in
my league right now i'm six foot five
six four and three quarters but six five
sounds a lot better
i work in youth development working with
kids my passion and being a positive
role model to them like what i had
growing up okay and i'm sorry i keep
looking at my notes i just want to make
sure i'm on track i'll be honest and
show you what it says
don't talk about boobs
he's my favorite i told you yeah he's
cool yeah yeah he's cool he could have
dressed up
yeah
you saw the t-shirt and you were like
come on man yeah i was like come on man
all right here we go okay we got a big
collar fella yeah
what up brandon what up theo shout out
to bama
uh this is vinnie out of charlotte north
carolina i'm a 32 year old single dad
i work for caterpillar during the day
and i'm a bouncer at night
like bama i'm sick of the dating life
and no commitments from anybody i'm
looking for something serious i can take
to the next level
i come from a big italian family uh real
down to earth loud people
um and i'm interested in that fancy face
you got this is christian so if you're
interested holler at me
backhoe oh
i'm not sorry i tell you why i don't
like him up top
he didn't say hi to me or steve yeah so
he's gotta go by felicia bye felicia oh
and that i didn't like his poofy hair
he's a solid dude he's a blue collar
dude though yeah alabama you interested
in being a stepmom though
um i have dated guys with kids so i'm
not opposed okay all right that's not a
deal breaker good to know
okay we'll watch uh two more and she can
then pick this guy gives a very una
bomber vibe
wait hold on one second hold on we got
to ask her one question
are you in the face are you into facial
hair
yes
it just i mean is it like a full
if drake's beard's over here and duck
dining sees over here he's more over
here
a lot are you a zz top
this guy looks like he smells like hemp
okay
yeah oh no
it looks like nobody's cool it looks
like he put his finger in an electric
socket
let him talk
and give him a chance he might be wrong
we're monsters
he's submitted a video on here man you
gotta go ahead
and give him a chance she's like oh [ __ ]
everybody
this is patrick
hello alabama my name is patrick i
currently live in windy wyoming i turned
31 in march i know a few years older
than you
i was at work listening to the podcast
and when i heard your voice my heart
immediately started to melt
when i got home i put it on youtube and
come to find out
you were flat out gorgeous yeah i'm sure
you will have a plethora of suitors and
a copious amount oh check out the
vocabulary on bob shining armor which
makes sense but i thought i'd send this
audition or resume in anyways
laugh
i have a huge heart and i'm an old
school helpless romantic yeah i like
this guy you know what he's my favorite
i know you know what it is he's right
now he's articulate yeah he's
articulated
and he's also uh like
he's a sweet eye yeah yeah he said that
he approached it
he was very respectful but you know i
don't know maybe you'd shave that
okay
this guy's pretty dying oh we got
competition here for that shirt but
let's see this is dylan uh but yeah like
that other guy i mean the beard's
temporary like he's living the single
life he's just letting it go i'm sure
he'd shave for alabama maybe it's like a
coke maybe it's like a coveted beard
thing you know yeah what would be more
yeah i got a cold beard
yeah that'd be cool
let's see what this does
sting what up eric and stevie thank you
like brendan
you know my heart goes out to theo
vaughn i i hope he recovers soon you
know i heard he got bit by a gay dude so
let's see
anyway let's see i'm sending this in man
i need to be linked up with alabama you
know what i'm saying this energy about
summit county colorado um
it's pretty tough dog you know
especially for a hard-working man i'm a
welder uh full-time you know you can see
with the high viz green except but uh
the thing is we got a saying here in
summit county you didn't lose your
girlfriend you just lost your turn
anyway i'm looking for the real deal i
want the the white picket fans the wife
the kids everything dogs so you know
please consider me um for alabama and as
far as mortgage goes girl real estate up
here we're talking vail keystone
breckenridge aspen you know you'd be
making that big bucks i i'll be barely
contributing you know what i mean not
really though just saying welders we
know how to do it big so anyway uh
consider me guys dylan out here in
summit county colorado
colorado
he's my mother
no no he's not by this too confident
i like i like that but
but not too cocky he also said like hey
i want you to move here with me yeah
yeah
he was like
and he and he presented it like yo
you're you know you could sell houses
here and like i like that guy he was
yeah i liked that guy yeah i liked him
too definitely best look in alabama
last one of the six
right what up king and the sting it's
your boy grayson coming at you from
austin texas
right now i'm learning how to be a
professional chef rat
but before that i used to live in salem
oregon so this is for alabama
um i used to work at starbucks and i
actually used to make you coffee uh i
don't forget that name um
so hopefully now i can make you dinner
all right maybe
um so why date me i am adventurous i'm
funny i could roast the [ __ ] out of you
um and i already know your coffee order
so
why don't you have a nice night in some
pasta maybe some wine um if you're
interested i'm your man let me know
see they're getting better you know what
the last three guys i like the last
three guys can we can we see all the
pictures again so we can like
you remember the first one right
here's nicholas nicholas was our first
he was good yeah nicholas is cool yeah
negative
he didn't he didn't say hi to us so i
don't know i don't like i don't like too
much hair product
for a for for a blue collar guy patrick
great heart this guy's got a good heart
yeah
dylan's by far my favorite and then the
chef in the sheffield yeah the last
quality too
the last two
so three guys you wanna if it was me it
would be this guy
dylan and the last guy the last guy yeah
the last girl yeah beard boys out
yeah i just don't i don't think she's
gonna go for it yeah
i don't really
so what do you think alabama which three
um i think the last three too yeah for
sure
i want to know if the guy knows my
coffee orders so because me too me too
because i was like well tell us what it
was dude yeah yeah how do we find that
out all right we're bringing him in oh
[ __ ] we're talking right now i guarantee
you he doesn't know it but still it was
a sea gesture let's see
oh he's doing work
oh yeah he's i love it he's
mid-welding i like it that would have
been cool if he was like
how's colorado buddy
uh it's cold bro we just got another
like foot last friday and
thank you for gearing up for ski season
i mean keystone right now okay i have
keystone
yes sir i have the cat in the bottom
right was he in the uh yeah that's easy
top does she see them uh
yeah she's oh she's you know she's okay
you can see them yeah i can see when
they talk yeah okay
how's it going if you if you switch are
you on a laptop or a cell phone
cell phone uh
there might be something where you press
gallery view and then you can see
everywhere yeah you need to see gallery
view the gallery
hold on
all right so we'll uh talk to these guys
one at a time ask them questions uh
welcome dylan patrick and vinnie
how's austin treating you good oh man
it's so much fun
okay
all right
i don't know where to go with that uh do
we have specific questions we want to
ask them like dating yeah alabama you
want to fire off the first question yeah
what do you want to do we'll take it
from there
sure going around the horizon yeah yeah
one of one one question for each
do you remember my coffee order
i'm very curious
it was like uh it was like uh okay i
don't know
yeah because
or dylan and patrick in he used to be
her barista uh before he moved into her
hometown before he moved to austin
apparently no i remember and he's now a
chef man type move
all right all right
um
dylan are you opposed to moving to
oregon
because you did mention moving to
colorado
yeah i just got back to colorado um i
lived here for six years and then i had
to take care of some family stuff in in
florida i was there for two
years and i literally just moved back um
on october 1st to colorado
so your boy signed that one year lease
he's tied down for a year yeah all right
so no
hard pass right now but we'll figure it
out it's relatively close i mean that's
your favorite so yeah brandon's favorite
got a minus one already yep got it
hey tia is a big airport bro
patrick i have a serious question and
don't take this the wrong way
ask it
would you ever get rid of the beard
ah
yeah definitely this was only uh really
for a character so yeah this is new to
me actually oh were you playing charles
manson
are you preparing for him to be jesus in
a christmas play
it could which one you know playing
charles manson on mine hunters yeah
no it looks good though dude i like that
[ __ ] sweater too though man it's cute
right holiday special yeah of course
honestly this is only about
two and a half
well a year and a half to be honest with
you that's a long time okay yeah yeah so
this is new to me so of course all right
fellas let's go around the horn what was
the last date you went on how'd it go
what'd you do
let's start with dylan
go ahead so the last day that we went on
uh so like
you get the cool bars are up in round
rock so like that's like the real cowboy
bars like it's not like hipster like in
austin like sixth street you're talking
about
not yeah outside there from dirty six
yeah you got to go up north like where
it's like the real bars and uh
i ended up just getting too drunk and i
had to call an uber so you're trying to
sell yourself man well he's just saying
his last date though did you did you
throw up so he's terrible on a date
that's what we know now
no no i did i didn't puke though i
didn't you just got too hammered
probably nervous it's a win yeah yeah
and then where did you meet that date at
was it a dating app we're talking about
instagram sending those dm's no i just
walked up to her i saw her at the mall i
was like hey oh i like that very 1990s i
dig it very old
very old 90s
all right fellas what was your last date
the other two
uh so first of all my last day was a
situation where i had met her at the bar
that i work at
and we went to this place uh in los
angeles that um
is a record listening party basically
and it's a shared experience and this dj
different djs show up each week
and um so we sat and listened to this uh
dj perform all these different uh um
songs that really inspired him and that
was a fantastic evening listening to all
those uh
griffith park i know it sounds a little
cheesy but we laid out a blanket and
watched the start and this was the first
time in a long time anything like that
happened but it was uh it worked well
and then and then often didn't work too
well what happened you guys aren't
dating anymore yeah they wrapped up the
night by killing sharon tate to be
honest with you i'm not even gonna lie
um
she was in an open relationship and uh
it after uh we had a few experiences
basically um
she went back to her uh full-on
relationship because she didn't want to
break the happy home so to speak make
sense
so you were a side piece
exactly i was totally a sidekick
i know i didn't i don't know if i felt
so comfortable about it but honest to
god the whole date of it all like the i
mean yeah music is great so uh something
like that is phenomenal and um yeah it
was it was nice now let me ask you this
we always talk about the outdoors yeah
were you guys uh doing drugs when you're
laying on your backs and watching the
stars
no no uh that's a shot nice um
yeah no uh shoot we are drinking
actually a little bit at the record
party but uh no drugs that's a nice date
my man [ __ ] you take me out yeah yeah
all right dylan what do you got bud so i
was actually uh i was at the show uh
that joe rogan caught covid at in tampa
um i i had a a a friend of mine um we
went and saw him and tony hinchcliffe
and laura bites um and it really wasn't
her cup of tea
um and she was actually a couple years
younger than me as well i'm 28
she was like 23 24. that's tough kind of
spent the whole night drinking and
partying and um you know i was i wanted
to hear you know the the new hours and
stuff so
um we just left it as friends uh
you know kind of that one one of those
deals but joe put on a great show
that's a good date though it's a good
date she just doesn't appreciate it
all right alabama it's a it's a cruel
world eliminate one and then we'll ask
the last do a couple more
worlds i like all three of them
this is hard i'm sorry guys um
i'm going to eliminate patrick
sorry patrick oh goodbye sweater
cheers merry christmas everyone thank
you manager you're a catch man yeah
yeah keep doing the goddamn thing yeah
you got great energy yeah i hope you get
the roll man good luck
oh yeah mad respect yeah no we got it
but maybe next week but maybe next time
don't do this weird the sweater and
beard just pick one
don't listen to it don't let eric bring
you down man that looks fly me yeah yeah
you [ __ ] can we can we replay
the things
okay
alabama do you have a question loaded
for these two another one oh gosh i
don't know um
i don't i can't think of anything let me
get ready to go with questions let me
help you out alabama fellas what's the
longest relationship you've been in
oh yeah
um
i'll i'll take it um i was in a very
serious relationship for about two and a
half years
um
and we just realized we wanted different
things uh especially geographically um i
i wanted to be up in the mountains and
uh she ended up just down in denver so
um you know to each his own still
friends but
about two and a half years longest and
you guys you guys broke up because of
location issues
um really where we wanted to be located
we lived together up the mountains and
she was over it um she was originally
she's a california girl man she did not
take well to i-70 in the snow
it's fair that's fair
i-70 is a nightmare
uh this is a question for both both of
the guys
uh what would you do to impress
alabama's parents
oh god
good luck
oh wow
here's what would happen we would go to
your parents house right
and then i would bring um
some homemade what do they like to eat
what do you like to eat
um i like basically anything italian
mexican food is like my favorite yeah
we're making
we can't make sushi but we're making
carbonara that's not good
we'll do that okay
we'll cook i'll cook for them and you
and then we'll have the wine
and we'll wind and dine them
that will work
nice yeah
it sounds like a nice night that's what
i got
for me um i'm a i'm an outdoorsy
type of guy you know i got i have two
dogs um i i live right by a bunch of
trail heads like i think you know maybe
meeting your folks out somewhere
um you know doing a really mellow hike
um yeah even just meeting them at like
one of the downtowns in one of the
villages breck go for uh you know a
flight of beer at the breck brewery or
um you know take a wine tour or
something like that where you know it's
not totally focused on us but we're able
to kind of mix and mingle get the folks
in there
other people are there having a good
time so yeah this is alabama coming to
you my name is the family and alabama
coming to you my man he wants to take
her parents on a beer crawl
i think that's it i think alabama can
choose her man and then we'll uh see if
they connect and then oh gosh yeah um
okay well i think you both are great
yeah
both of you so far um i think i'd like
to get to know dylan a little bit better
for sure um you seem really cool with
the outdoorsiness and the fact that you
have two dogs i have a dog so um people
who understand how dogs are perfect if
you have the patience for a puppy that's
that's what i need so
yeah
awesome well congrats you were great
yeah great
grace we'll find
stuff man keep going with that hey
thanks boys yeah good luck brother
all right we'll connect you to off air
thanks everybody yeah it doesn't alabama
you killed it hopefully this helped uh
if you have any problems reach out yeah
yeah but
we'll do it rough nick joseph timberlake
right here is gonna be all right yeah
appreciate you guys man thanks for
playing
gang buzz buzz buzz buzz lover birds
take care
gang gang love love you're right i don't
think that's gonna work out why
well he doesn't want to move well
everything was like yeah you'd fly out
here seven hour road trip yeah and then
uh
crawl your parents to fly their [ __ ]
asses from eugene oregon and then uh the
guy with the beard's tough man it's a
certain style it's like that hipster
charles manson the family vibe you know
i'm saying it's a real particular taste
yeah but he but he was artsier than the
other ones he was you know
yeah because there was no reason to pick
that guy no it didn't make he said i'm
not moving i'm not moving you're asking
here even your parents got to come here
yeah he lives in you know in the in
summit the other guy knows your coffee
order i'm from i'm from colorado that's
a big basement
they'll probably smash and then i don't
think so i don't think they ever see
each other i think she digs that though
because he's he's just straight up he's
being honest
i think she digs that yeah i think
she'll go they'll see each other i'll
give you that impression
remember i studied this question
first of all she already knows she
already knows too he he just said
in the thing
i don't do long distance
you know what i mean she's very upfront
yeah she's attractive that's very
attractive he's like yeah [ __ ] you have
to sell your [ __ ] move out of here she
likes the way he looks and just say it
of course that's the number one thing
that was the main thing yeah the number
one i don't know how we're just gonna
pretend looks don't matter you know what
i'm saying we do though i'm just saying
like you want to pretend you know she
doesn't want to seem shallow like that
but
so what's gonna happen are they gonna
get hooked up like that what happened
yeah my wife wouldn't be there if she
looked like a warlock you know
it'll just go by the wayside so what do
you guys do
well we did but remember the girl jim
went on a date with with the big titties
she actually got married
well what happened to the other remember
the one that was like this she was like
mixed race oh yeah she got murdered
it didn't work out with her she said the
guys were flaky honestly she sounded
like she was a little hard to do
high maintenance she wasn't happy with
i really like this segment though you
should keep doing it i like it i i think
it's really funny yeah we just for once
we gotta find three girls yeah we gotta
find some girls
because alabama's a dime piece we have
all these dime pieces and then it's like
two good looking guys the rest are
[ __ ] warlocks you know it's tough for
the girls okay i i think it will help if
we have really desirable guys so if
you're a guy who wants to play a dating
game with and see a bunch of suitors
send in your resume yeah what you do why
you should be bro you know who we could
hook up on here is mark harley
yeah
he's single he's recently single and
girl's [ __ ] like oh he's a beast we
would and if he put up hey submit the
king of the states yeah
dime all right guys don't submit we have
our uh
[Applause]
yeah
and we should also try to let people
know like hey they're from this place so
shout out to that that place like she's
from where she's like she's from oregon
yeah it should have been like hey oregon
people you know what i mean she says
where she's from and we only get so many
so that's true good stuff but uh yeah i
don't know i agree it's fun well mark
would be great though yeah oh yeah we'll
close out with a couple of uh kinder
stingers
[Music]
gonna like him no you see i don't like
the violence i like their ass shake up
them down i i i
i just don't i've never liked strippers
you're in a good strip club though yes
like which welcome what dude is wrong
with you you've never been to magic city
in atlanta
but no i have not been a man i don't
like strip clubs because i'm because i i
feel like i become eric save a hoe
because i'm like
why are you here you know what i mean i
am gentlemen
but i am too like what you doing here
girl
when they're like my name's cinnamon i'm
like sit down yeah what's your real name
when i went to strip clubs i always end
up gravitating towards like there's
always like a bartender who's not a
stripper and she's like you could tell
she's got contempt for the stripper and
that's the one i'm like what you become
a therapist yeah yeah just i can't i
can't get into it stevie i feel like you
spend all your cash
well i haven't in many years um but when
you used to go i bet it was lit as [ __ ]
well i went to the ones around my
neighborhood because i don't have a car
so i'd walk to the one on la brea sure
um but i'd always you know the bad
things about ihops blue balls you get
blue balls because you know you're there
now if you're playing the right game but
yeah i don't know how to play that game
yeah all right oh yeah okay all right
well yeah no one's been uh
i have a terrible strip club story but i
tell another time i'd love to hear it
yeah yeah no we want to hear it that's
better than the submissions we have
left well i knew this girl she used to
come by the comedy store too and she was
like this like ex playmate whatever it
is right so she um and this was way
before i was single as hell sure and she
was like um
she was like oh i'm in vegas i was in
vegas doing shows and she's like
randomly hit me up like come to
spearmint rhino you know
that's been a baddie though yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you sent
me a picture of herself and her friend
that was there last girl you know what i
mean i was like all right let me go so i
get there and i go so here's the first
thing i get
i'm so inexperienced with this so i get
to the door and i'm like okay so like
whatever her stripper name was i forgot
it at this time let's say it was
cinnamon i'd be like yeah they're like
we don't know who whatever you still got
to pay to get in yeah i'm thinking my
name's at the door
there's no will called yeah yeah yeah
yeah so then i walk in and then like
immediately
immediately you get like harassed now if
you're like a nice guy
they take advantage they take advantage
it's a feeding frame you know why
because they know you're not supposed to
be in here so they really going after
yeah you know so then you know it's like
a used car salesman you look like the
dad that walked in looking for his
daughter you know what i mean it was
like yo yo yo yo and so then i see them
and i'm like god damn they got they're
like looking dope they want to get
drinks i go let's get some all right i
go but i don't drink are you by yourself
at this point i'm by myself gangster
yeah so i'm like all right you want to i
got this kitchen so i get to the bar and
they order what they order then the
bartender looks at me
he's like uh yeah it's gonna be sixty
dollars i'm like what hell yeah so i'm
like okay and then it was like they just
walking me around and then they go hey
let's go to this one room the boom boom
room let's go this room so we go in the
room you know and but it was like a
hundred dollars each time yes per dance
you know and i'm like okay but stuff was
happening that probably don't normally
happen sure oh it does but carry on okay
whatever you're special yeah yeah they
were they were what makes you feel good
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
we walk around someone they go we should
go to this other room yes
that's upstairs i feel like though we
just went in a circle and went back into
the same room
they thought you were talking about my
[ __ ] is that my jacket
so we in the same room so now it's too
long story short
i'm out a thousand dollars
i'm out a thousand dollars and i'm like
i i when i walked out of the street you
think about what you're making that
weekend and she's like dude what just
did i just get taken by somebody you got
hustle claim to be my friend yeah yeah
never talk to that [ __ ] again no never
you know i was like why would you like
it's like okay
that's how you want to be that's how
they roll man oh man just that they
smell just a mile away though like yeah
like [ __ ] you know dude yeah i was like
what what am i doing
like what am i doing in here you know
what i mean i hate you in life yeah
i didn't even finish
you know and then the reason like you go
to a strip club i guess because you
think like well i don't wanna whatever
the rationale is it would have been
easier if i would have just said to her
just come to my hotel and i give you
five hundred dollars yeah more than
about 100 but yeah
i'm i'm saying yeah why go through all
that rigmarole yeah
why do i go through this like pretending
like you're interested in saying
here's 500 just come to my hotel right
it's like but people you don't want to
do that because it feels slimier now you
can you can feel slimier yeah you can
just go and go how much making tonight
like let's get the [ __ ] out of here's
two grand
i've heard of people
now the same way brenda gets triggered
by ufc the smell of ufc fights
yeah yeah i just cause i know you just
you go like oh i can't trust none of
y'all i think your tommy bahama shirt
gave it away when you walked in you feel
me
they're like
you got that dad energy it i did yeah no
but i had no the energy i had they
probably said he probably got a family
he ain't supposed to be a hundred
percent get him and they exactly it's
like you're chum in the water you know
the sharks come out with big tips
the people that survive in strip clubs
are probably super [ __ ] guys because
they know or or you know that they're
there when they're like oh you know the
game or you know the game yeah but yeah
you got to be [ __ ]
put this quarter in your butthole
or the worst is when you get there and
like the worst looking stripper approach
you first like come on [ __ ] come on
you're [ __ ] up the game i was in
kansas city and uh the the what's the
stanford and sons the guy died there
owns the club okay but he was he was a
maniac
he took me to a strip club the strip
club was so terrible
i was the big attraction in the strip
club that's how bad the strippers yeah
the strippers can't be good yeah yeah
kansas city because i'm sitting there
and yeah
you know and everybody still
you know what i mean but her c-section
starts like you know what i mean it's
like
when i'm the attraction butterfly
all the tattoos are saggy because you
know what i mean it's a nightmare yeah
they just do a field trip king of the
sting strip club night
i'm down
nick would go dead broke in that [ __ ]
i'm a little bit more like eric i never
lost it but like that's always been like
my perception like they're just they're
just taking me back as a group it's fun
yeah man you'll be in there doing that
make it a field trip doing parlay bets
he's got the biggest titties
no nick's the guy where we're all as a
crew and they're like really [ __ ]
he's in the [ __ ] private room doesn't
know they took his credit card nine
dances later he's like seventeen grand
yeah it's a waste well they ain't
getting that no yeah
he already called the company like yeah
you put his phone right
this fraudulent charge then you
basically get one you know then you
bring christian calendar they find the
one fat [ __ ]
getting married and [ __ ] christian like
nah man she good the short kings find
their big queen yeah that'd be lit oh
wow yeah just double team on her that's
all we got they like big girls
that's it man hey uh
hollywood improv december 22nd that's
next wednesday you will be there and
some other hilarious people one night
only one show 8 p.m hollywood improv all
right get your tickets now because only
one show that [ __ ] is selling out and
then december 30th through january 1st
i'm in fort lauderdale florida dania
florida bringing the new years with your
thick friend here and the crew chappelle
lacy and david lucas
and then in january i'm in north
carolina twice i'm in raleigh north
carolina and then also charlotte north
carolina so get your tickets right now
fam yeah i don't got a lot well i got
some other stuff but i'm in arizona this
weekend so i'm gonna stand up live this
weekend and then
actually i just added on a show on the
16th at that other club they have in
arizona now in uh scottsdale this airs
on the 16th so yeah yeah
oh well that doesn't matter anyway so
come tomorrow to stand up live yep um i
me and jeremiah are gonna be at seoul
joel's
january 8th uh doing a scissor bros live
podcast i also can i plug my music with
just one of my out i have a new music
project on spotify so type in
q-u-a-n-g-o-u the album is called i feel
stir crazy so check it out is it it was
like punk rock or were we talking about
no it's just like underground rap stuff
did all the production of it yeah if you
want yeah we'll go out we'll go if you
want hit it nick yeah
the stuff he got a good song about his
dad oh
yeah you can play this is this you
singing oh that's a sample
[Music]
what's the best song to play on here
stevie i like this one
[Music]
[Music]
he does it in his bathroom and the ac is
on
souljules
go get stevie's music
[Music]
griffin back do2 yeah you know how we do
it so just tune in for the laughs theo
said that he was on his way but ran out
of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at paw
way
now he only finished boys in the hallway
this ain't the greatest show on earth
and what you call that eric griffin with
them he the nate dogger podcast
get a whole crew sick it's the king in
the state what up chin what up nick
stevie weeby eric griffin just walked in
and got it lit you can't forget about
brendan he still need everything dick
dick they still got the bees and the
trap trapping still the king and the
sting so quit asking if you know then
you know it's a cat's thing ball and
chain hair swang like the rat cam king
and the stink
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan theo too yeah you
know how we do it so just tune in for
the laughs theo said that he was on his
way but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting